good evening Fernando welcome to Piers
Morgan on Center well it's not been a
quiet few days that's it the goat has
bolted Cristiano Ronaldo out at Old
Trafford after using his bombshell
interview with me on this show just at
the record straight about what was going
on at the club and his concerns well
tonight I'm going to set the record
straight myself on Cristiano Ronaldo and
on that interview because one week on is
still making Global headlines
breaking news Cristiano with all those
time at Old Trafford officially over
Manchester United saying that they have
mutually parted ways effective
immediately all of this stems from that
explosive interview with Piers Morgan
Cristiano Ronaldo has left Manchester
United with immediate effect it follows
a TV interview with Piers Morgan where
he claimed he felt disrespected and then
that explosive interview that he had
with Piers Morgan saying those uh very
hurtful things about Manchester United
and after an explosive interview with
Piers Morgan the writing seemed to be on
the wall
like I said it was explosive well this
Show's been at the center of a true
Global story and that story really is
only just beginning because minutes
after Ronaldo confirmed he'd leave
United by Mutual consent the Glazer
family who own the club confirm they're
looking to sell American Family bought
Manchester United for 1.3 billion
dollars in 2005. now they may get four
times that amount and if that sounds
like good business well it is for them
but that's precisely why United fans
have such a problem with the glazes who
loaded United with debt and presided are
a steady but massive decline on the
pitch they seem more concerned about
selling shirts and shares than winning
Trophies the opposite of what English
football should be about this is what
Ronaldo himself said to me about the
glazes
the owners of the club they listen they
don't the glazes the glazes they don't
they don't care about about the club I
mean
professional uh sport
as you know this Manchester is a
marketing Club they will get
his money from the marketing
the sports
it's that that don't really care in my
opinion
the funds are they're always right I
think the fans should know the true
should know that
the place we want the best for the club
so did Ronaldo's condemnation of the
glazes force the issue after years of
protests by supporters you can judge
that for yourself when the biggest
superstar in the club's history calls
out mismanagement at the very top how
could their position be tenable
supporters and Club Legends like Roy
Keane and Gary Neville have also slammed
the glazes it's never even called on
Ronaldo to use his status to put them
under pressure stand up now and speak
you wrote this summer The Club is in
crisis it needs its leaders to lead
Ronaldo's the only one who can grab a
situation by the scruffer the neck
exclamation mark So Ronaldo did speak
out and the same Gary Neville said he
should be Savage
I don't know what's going on but since
since the Sarah Alex Ferguson left I saw
not evolution in the club the progress
was Zero nothing changed surprisingly
natural only the pulled the jacuzzi even
the gym
even some points of Technology the
kitchen
the chefs which is I appreciate lovely
lovely persons they stop in a in a time
we see many
things that I'm used to seeing when I
was 20 21 23 so surprised me a lot
well 13 years after a spectacular first
battle United Ronaldo returned to funny
Club but had only gone backwards in his
View and that's the real reason he
wanted to do this interview in the first
place he just had enough and he felt he
wasn't getting the respect that his
extraordinary career deserved and all
the fans getting what they deserve the
supporting United week in week out last
season Ronaldo scored 24 goals for
teaming total turmoil one Premier League
goal more than Harry Kane England's
Captain who is considered one of the top
Strikers in the world right now but
still they blamed Ronaldo his own coach
Eric tinhard disrespected him repeatedly
in public journalists cashed in on his
status for click bait many of the story
is completely untrue Ronaldo soaked all
this up for a long time even though many
of the stories about him were false and
hurtful
and I'm also the lie that he skipped
pre-season training to force a transfer
when in fact his baby daughter was sick
in hospital just months after her twin
brother had tragically died
Ronaldo told me the executives of the
club didn't even believe him
I wonder he felt very little loyalty to
them in return well now this chapter in
his record-breaking career is over many
people have accused me of using Ronaldo
speculating that he must surely regret
ever sitting down with me in fact the
opposite is true he's very happy with
everything about the interview he said
what he wanted to say and he spoke
because he wanted to speak he texted me
repeatedly this week all good as we said
on Friday when it finally all add as
he's in Doha now in Qatar to Captain
Portugal at the World Cup the future is
great he says that I reckon for him it
probably will be even at 37 he's a mega
star the biggest icon in football
history with half a billion Instagram
followers but that in context 130
million more than his nearest rival
Lionel Messi his rival for everything
we're not as a merchandising monster or
make a fortune whichever Club he signs
for he's still a gold machine too you
don't go from scoring 24 goals last
season to a terrible striker in four or
five months
there's been a lot of knee-jerk reaction
from some United fans claiming he's
trashed his legacy at the club really
literally one of the greatest ever ever
put on a United shirt you were lucky to
have him lucky to watch him show him a
bit more respect
Ronaldo won't take a penny to leave he's
foregone any of his remaining 17 million
pounds left on his deal all he wants is
his freedom and to go and try his luck
somewhere else where he hopes he'll be
given more respect and if his legacy is
ultimately to get rid of the glazes from
Manchester United in his football all
those people criticizing now will
probably be cheering him and saying
thank you Cristiano
out of the football subject of football
and thanks my sincere thanks also go to
the first team that manages to get
through a day of this tournament without
a pathetic piece of virtue signaling
today it was the Germans you might have
been following this
increasingly ludicrous debate over
whether people should wear armbands to
show their support for the LGBT
community
full disclosure I'm completely
supportive of All lgbtq rights always
happening
but I never understood this whole thing
about the armband I want players to play
football the World Cup not a virtue
signal and it's all gone exactly how I
predicted which is that actually when
they were threatened for the first time
with the booking which is someone waving
a yellow card at them
they've all capitulated the German team
today
did this
I mean really this is to send a point to
FIFA that they've been silenced they've
been gagged they can't wear their
armbands oh get over yourselves
it's honestly embarrassing
England have been embarrassing about
this Captain Harry Kane was going to
wear his armband show his great support
for the community okay we'll do it then
we're armband
don't then bottle it because you might
get a yellow card
if any player right now
at the World Cup where is one of these
armbands which I don't think they should
be doing anyway because I don't achieve
anything
any one of them did it right now and got
a booking they'd be Global Heroes
probably get a Knighthood
but none of them have got the balls
under Ray Winston one of my favorite
actors about what he said about this
today
Harry you can't let them tell you what
to do
if they booked you
it probably sends you off an effect
though
imagine if Harry Gane got sent off for
wearing an armband supporting one love
all hell would break loose and not at
him he'd be a hero around the world
so then bottle it honestly embarrassing
for Harry for England for the fa and for
the Germans to do what they did today
and he I keep thinking if you don't
focus on the football you know what
happens Germany got beaten
by Japan that's what happens when you're
more worried about
shh than you are about stopping goals
flying in the back of your network